Yes. I think this is a good time to move on to our three by threes.
Now there's a reason why I have my laptop is because we're going to create a
three. We're going to share each other's three by three of anime.
We've explained at the beginning of the way, we're three by three songs,
but like to expand further on that, I like,
I love seeing people's three by three, right? Cause I,
I feel like a three by three is the closest thing you get to a Rorschach test
for like automate fans. You know what I mean? Cause you, you get,
you got to see cause like, like asking,
asking what someone's favorite anime is, is like a stupid question because like,
if you've seen enough changes all the time, it changes all the time.
But like we've, we've like, we've like, uh, kind of with nine animated,
choose from that's a good sample size to really get a grasp on what this
person's taste is. Like. Not, not, not if all their tastes,
because I dunno how hard a time you guys had choosing nine anime.
I was just shoved through to get nine to get that I liked.
But I had a pretty difficult time just choosing my anatomy.
You probably have like a seizure just thinking like,
what am I going to do for like breakfast? Like, Oh my God, like Jesus Christ.
Like, that's why you like take so long to contemplate decisions.
I mean,
I can come up with mine pretty quickly just because like I literally thought of
the first night we're going to look at mine first,
but I literally just thought of the first nine that I think is like, yeah,
I love this because I think that's the most important thing is like, I feel,
if you think too hard about it, then you're kind of reshaping your tastes.
It's just generally just a bad policy. So I was, I was like, all right,
what are the nice shows that I love? Just a bad post
thinking is overrated. I just go with a gut that an unpopular opinion,
unpopular opinions. Thinking's overrated. All right.
So let's look at mine first. All right. Let's see what you got here, Joe.
[inaudible]
do you want to introduce to the audience who cannot see or don't go to these
shows? What? So from,
so top row from left to right is serial experiments lane clan add fully coli.
Middle row is princess Mononoke. Lucky stop on. Okay.
And then bottom row is [inaudible] one of the tire series. You Hawkshaw.
Why? Lucky star. I I've got her.
[inaudible] I it's quite it's right.
Bang there in the sense of staring at me again,
don't worry about placements too much. Don't worry about placements too much.
This could be an any random order. Yeah. Reason why. Okay.
I completely get why someone would look at me and say for our lucky stars,
not good because truth be told if you watch lucky star today,
it'd probably be. Right?
Lucky star to me is so time sensitive because all of its jokes
are time sensitive.
Like lucky style was one of those shows that made fun of like otaku and
weed culture back in like the mid two thousands. Um,
I'm turning this into a like video. I'll tell you a lucky star.
My friend, lucky star is a Reddit humor before.
That's it's it's it's like the it's like the late two thousands Reddit here and
the Reddit just didn't exist. So I don't know. I was just like, Oh, lucky size.
Amazing. Huh?
I couldn't sit through it. Really? No, I didn't finish it. I.
Say like, it's weird because random,
a couple of days ago I was just scrolling through YouTube and on my recommended,
there was just like a lucky star, like funny compilation. And I was just like,
I haven't heard of lucky. It was like six minutes long. I'm like, you know what?
it. I've got time. It sounds like an oxymoron to me. Lucky stuff.
Funny compilation. But I dunno.
I think it's because like, especially around,
around the time when I watch lucky star,
I was like really heavily into obviously of course like anime obviously,
but I was really heavily into like the otaku culture,
especially in Japan and lucky star kind of went over all of that and
put it into perspective of like it's pretty ridiculous.
Looking from an outsider's perspective.
Yeah. I just cafes weird, huh?
Yeah, no, not even that. It was just like, like the we get seen.
It's still funny to this day just because it's so accurate. I mean, I just,
I look back at lucky star and I never liked it originally,
but I looked back at some of the scenes. I'm just like, yeah, this doesn't age.
Well to me at all. Right, exactly.
And that's why I never recommend lucky star to people today because it has not
aged. Well, the jokes have not age. Well, I have a question.
What the is this show in the bottom corner I've seen.
The bottom left. What does that show English name of that,
uh, God, I haven't even, I think I've watched that show. It's basically,
it's basically like a comedy show that throws in a lot of itchy jokes and like
sexual jokes. I've watched the show and I don't remember anything.
I, a hundred percent I've watched the show. I'm one small,
small girls angry that she doesn't have big. Right, right.
That's one of the jokes. Yeah.
You funny? Yeah. Okay. Why, why is this in your three buckets?
This is in my three by three because a, well, first of all,
I think it's hilarious.
It kind of my love for comedy and my love for ECI.
Broad term of what comedy is. Um, lucky star.
Your love for comedy art. What about the show that comes to this?
Your love for comedy? I think it's fun. I mean, I don't know what else,
what the,
because it's very intricate in the jokes that constructed a very, this,
this, okay.
The reason why I put this and it's because it encompasses my love for trashy
shows. Oh, this show is not good. In any perspective.
I'm just saying it right now. All right. Here's how you know that my, you know,
my three by three is legit. Right? Give me some of the
[inaudible] is not a good show. It is trashy comedy. Okay. With ECI jokes,
they're actually bugging me. All right. Okay.
Here's the reason why I put it in important question then every show here. Yeah.
Would you rewatch it today? Yeah, you would. I would.
You've rewatched lucky stone. I've did I not to say that?
I was literally watching.
Two days ago. I just thought it was a lie. Honestly. I just didn't believe it.
Well, I would a hundred percent rewatch all these shows today. I got to say,
I was like, I didn't put it on, but I was this close to putting you on the show.
I am glad that you put it in because it represents my love for sure.
I gotta be honest. Right, boys.
I legitimately try to watch you hack shirt no less than a week ago. Right?
I put it on first episode and I was like, I can't watch this.
Like I thought it was the DOB and I was like the dubs too awful.
I switched the Japanese. I'm like. It's woeful as well. I can't stand.
What are you talking about?
The audio was driving me insane. Like I actually couldn't watch it.
It was such bad quality. I know that it's old, but like,
I actually couldn't sit there.
So basically your review of you Huck show is where it's old there. Honestly.
That I'm like that. But like I was like, I actually, Oh my God.
Really going to hit me with that.
What was your, what was your problem with the audience?
Cause like you Huck show from what I remember was like one of my favorite dubs,
I never watched it.
I swear 10 seconds into the DOB light fire. Listen to the Japanese. I gotta,
I gotta, I gotta turn this off.
It's pretty bad. The paid use gay. Cause you scare, you like killed it.
This is probably just a case of, you know, uh, you know,
watching it years later and being spoiled for choice, et cetera, et cetera.
Okay. Like I put you Hutcher there because obviously I love my shining,
but I feel like, I don't know.
I've never felt the same level of excitement that I felt watching and Hawkshaw
that I have from any I'm envious. I want that you,
hockey show has some of my favorite arcs in all have shown in the dark
tournament, Ark Tuesday, one of the best arcs in showing Shona,
the dark tournament arc is the best tournament arc hands-down of all time.
And this is, this is a tournament arc that came out 20 years ago. Now. Like it,
it, it birth the tournament Alejandra. The reason why,
the reason why tournament arcs have become a meme and are so hyped is because of
you because of you, you like Dragonball. Might've like popularized it.
Perfect. It hasn't been perfected since then.
But like also like we is one of the best villains in all
shown in as well. [inaudible] Oh my God. Such a good character.
Not going to lie growing up. I want it to be here so bad. I was like,
I looked at here and I'm just like everything about this guy
[inaudible] is so cool.
Experiments laying at.
The tall. Yeah. That's top left. Why? I think because like, well again,
I still think it's insanely ahead of its time.
Like this was made back in like the late and it talks about societal issues
that are relevant today. Right. And that's, I don't know.
I think that's like a huge artist.
Like what type of stuff that they talk about in the show,
what kind of societal basically grossly over-simplify Cyril experiments lane is
essentially this idea that your digital identity and your real life identity
sees no barrier.
And so basically it follows obviously lane who kind of goes through this like
discovery of herself and the world in being like,
wait so we can create digital identities of ourselves on the quote unquote
internet. I mean, obviously back then it was very primal. Right.
But came out in 1990, 98, eight. Yeah. And just,
just to give it didn't even have balloons tout offense for flash play,
but basically it's, it's this idea that like, wait,
so if things happen in the digital world then is there really no
consequences of that in the real world environment?
And they did that in 12 episodes and it's it's, uh, I,
I will test that, see what we're experiencing.
It's amazing because I remember I watched it for the first time last year.
So I watched it pretty well cause he was on my to watch this forever.
And then I was just like, you know, I'm finally in the mood to watch this.
I'll give it a watch. And I remember thinking, man, this,
normally when you see a piece of media that focuses around technology and like
stories around technology, it ages horribly.
I remember watching Sarah expense land. I'm thinking, how is this?
How does this seem like it's more relevant now than it is when it first
came out? Let show 20 years. Sure. Low key foretold.
The future of social media. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I think,
I think I gotta understand that if you are really in touch with the internet
back then you could probably see where it was going. I think. And I think,
and obviously I picked serial experiments like that, obviously,
because I love it. But also I love, I mean the shows that make you think,
quote, unquote, that to dive more into that kind of stuff, like, you know,
make you thunk, right? Like vulgar proxy is in the same field as that.
I love that show and uh, you know, Raza, Fon as well was in there as well.
Climate. I mean, I just think it's good. Hey, made me cry.
Made me cry. My love for my to journey.
Both my love for no fair enough
really is just a master seven episodes.
And it feels like a five-hour long movie. It's it's a very dense show.
Very. I would say he does not. Why does dance always just sound like an insult?
It's a fiction. What'd you want to say? No, no. It's it's a, it's a compact
compact SUV. So did salt.
The dense dense sounds like it's like sh like brick house, like
garbage. It's a compact show.
Cause there is like Callie has 24.
I would dare say 24 episodes worth of material packed into seven episodes.
I would agree with that. Yeah. And it's got the soundtrack.
One of the best soundtracks of all time track is amazing. amazing.
I've no more questions. You're free to go. Yeah. Okay. Wait a minute. No, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
You had a choice of any anime movies and you pick a Ghibli movie. I mean,
look man, you gave this a 10 out of 10 wasn't on your list
and you also didn't change that school. So it's a good movie.
Would I put it as like any movie is the best anime movie going?
He's going to say your name. You're you're you're you're you're gonna find out.